if you only buy your paper products from
dunder mifflin
and the gang at the office here are five
other titles worth checking out on this
week's
binge guide with eight of nine fresh
seasons under its belt the office has
cemented itself as one of the greatest
sitcoms of all time
and is regaining popularity with a new
audience in the streaming age
and with trips to places like a parks
department a sheriff's department
and an i.t department this list will
fill your office void
starting with our certified fresh pick
parks and recreation
premiering back in 2009 this
mockumentary following the inner
workings of a parks and recreation
department
ran for seven mostly certified fresh
seasons on nbc
and one of the show's creators michael
sher has also brought us comedies like
the good place and brooklyn nine-nine
both of which you should also check out
critics call this one of the very best
sitcoms on television praising it for
finding fresh ways
of utilizing its lovable ensemble and
for being heartfelt yet hilarious
and snarky yet good-natured you can
binge this show in just under 46 hours
and don't forget the rest of michael
shurer's comedies which should fill up
your binge calendar
until about 2022. dialing in with our
editor's pick this week is
reno911 after six successful seasons on
comedy central starting back in 2003
this improvised show about inept
officers in a county sheriff's
department
returned this year for a fresh season
run on quibby the show which also
spawned the 2007
film reno 911 miami has been praised by
critics for being an anarchically
hilarious ride-along
you can binge all seven seasons and the
movie in about 36 and a half hours for a
throwback pick this week we're heading
back to
2012 for the mindy project with six
fresh seasons
three airing on fox and three on hulu
this show is about a young ob gyn
trying to balance her professional and
personal life and trying to match the
fairy tale
endings of her favorite romantic
comedies after kickstarting her career
on the office
star and creator mindy kaling shines in
what critics call a charming comedy
where she earns consistent laughs with
her wit charm
and physical comedy it'll take you about
54 and a half hours to binge all
six seasons and you will eventually
learn that real life
is nothing like romantic comedy remotely
accessing our audience pick this week is
the it crowd this british comedy ran for
four seasons
starting in 2006 and is about the
humorous adventures of a ragtag team of
it
workers at a huge corporation that's
headed by a temperamental yuppie
critics say that this show which helped
launch the career of chris o'dowd
is a brainy riot that is consistently
funny and inventive
you can binge this one in just about 10
and a half hours
but if you do it on your work computer
you actually might hear from it
and finally our brand new pick this week
is superstore
this nbc workplace comedy with five
fresh seasons and a brand new sixth
season
follows employees working at a big box
store while taking a comedic approach to
timely more heavy issues with a charming
cast led by the emmy-winning america
ferreira
critics call superstore one of the most
lovable ensembles on television
you can binge the first five seasons in
just over 37 hours
which is about the same amount of time
you need to walk every aisle at your
local superstore
okay hopefully this list will help firm
up your next few binge sessions
that's what she said let us know what
you're currently streaming in the
comments
and be sure to check out the new rotten
tomatoes is
wrong a podcast from rotten tomatoes
because fresh and rotten is just the
beginning
of the conversation new episodes drop
every thursday
and you might be looking at one of the
two hosts of that show look if you don't
want to miss out on any recommendations
based on the shows and movies you love
make sure you hit that notification bell
and subscribe button
i'm mark ellis this has been the rotten
tomatoes binge guide and we'll see you
in the next vid
[Music]
you